c'est une première à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines un
cycle de conférences sur la thématique
du genre est organisée à partir de ce
mois de janvier jusqu'au mois de mars
dans la structure au programme quatre
rendez-vous pour débattre sur l'égalité
entre les sexes et les préjugés dans la
société française on peut modifier les
représentations et on peut modifier les
stéréotypes de sexe bien sûr dans un
domaine comme la physique ou arriver à
ce qu on a 35 pour cent des étudiantes
contre 65 % d'étudiants
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de l'impact des stéréotypes de
genre dont le choix d orientation des
étudiantes pour ouvrir ce cycle une
conférence sur les femmes du laboratoire
de marie curie était programmé
l'histoire de la chercheuse prix nobel
de physique en 1903 et prix nobel de
chimie en 1911 attiré une centaine de
personnes s'est en fait marie curie née
que né le que le prétexte justement pour
présenter le fait qu'elle n'était pas
seule femme scientifique de son époque
et éventuellement le rôle qu'elle a joué
mais surtout le rôle que l'histoire lui
a fait jouer dans dans cette définition
d'une femme scientifique
le cycle de conférence se terminera le
31 mars il abordera entre autres les
questions de l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin ou encore la thématique de la
place des femmes dans le milieu
artistique